the jurgen experience i'm watching this
trial like it's a cautionary tale
it's a cautionary tale about believing
in [ __ ]
like forming a narrative in your head
like we're rebels together we're gonna
yeah you know it's that's what i felt
like about anthony bourdain in his
relationship too that crazy woman
but
and then you're seeing it all play out
in court
like you've seen all the crazy come out
you know do you know the fact like he
talked about her [ __ ] in his bed
yeah yeah it's great
so hot it's do you think no no no right
it's a real real problem
hard to forget it's a real problem
that's hard to forget but she said that
she used this specific makeup to cover
all of her bruises that johnny gave her
which is not true
specific makeup and that specific well
the problem is it was a specific makeup
it turns out that the company didn't
even make that makeup
at the time that she was claiming she
was using it oh wow
that's great really yeah but that's what
happens with people like that yeah
people that are just completely
manipulative and full of [ __ ] like that
doug stanhope knows her his dan helps
stanhope's buddies with uh johnny depp
and he wrote something about you know
like i forget what he wrote i think he
wrote like a little essay about how full
of [ __ ] she is and she threatened to sue
him and i think he had to wind up taking
it down i hope i'm not [ __ ] that up
but uh he knows her he knows her well
and he's like she's out of her [ __ ]
mind and i'm like like like a crazy
actress he's like yeah like those are
real
of course there's a ton of them there's
a lot of them that's why they're good
that is why they're good yeah they're
great actresses they're just like crying
oh yeah
yeah it's the whole johnny depp thing is
just
he was famous when he was 20. and i
don't think you get any kind of
perspective like that i think you're
[ __ ]
it's like it's like making cement but
you don't add in all the ingredients and
it's like oh it never cured right yeah
well i i mean johnny dep what happened
he looks it's rough it's 55 years of
coke
[Laughter]
he's not 75. he looks great for what
he's doing he's like 60
right
we have it that he started after he's
already started doing cooking
how old is johnny's up
he's got to be 60.
what is he 58 58 50. he looks like it's
55 years of donuts coke it would make
you look thin and now well he's not
athletic he's not like working out yeah
he's not taking care of himself and
for a long time at least he smokes
cigarettes i don't know if he still does
but
all those factors
they contribute to poor health
he's he the outfits aren't great either
where is she shopping yeah he's uh
both of them right yeah she's copying
him supposedly she like mimics his
outfits
what's going on here uh i just had a
weird tie on oh it's just white
just white that looks like it's for it's
very short i think that's a vest yeah
okay okay
it's tucked into a vest oh okay that is
a vest yeah it's hard we're looking at
low resolution photos
i mean the whole thing is just he has a
bob
here's the problem even if he wins she
doesn't have any money
like
if he gets 50 million dollars in a
settlement the only good thing is
everybody knows now and this is a good
thing this is one of the reasons why
it's good that you did this everyone
knows now like there's something wrong
with her
yeah like there's something wrong right
there's some sort of like
mental issue whatever there's a lot of
mental issues and you said she [ __ ] in
his bed see i didn't say that they said
that who's they the people on the news
[Laughter]
well they're always right
that's what i found out the last year
okay so they said that she [ __ ] in his
bed for what reason to mark territory
johnny depp testified my vampire heard
ate a cheesy gordita crunch from taco
bell before
breaking news
[Laughter]
okay let's see
that might be fake news
we're going to find out whether or not
amber heard [ __ ] in the bed next on the
joe rogan experience
[Music]
newsweek
okay clips of johnny depp accusing amber
heard of defecating in bed go viral
imagine what a slow week for news
newsweek is like [ __ ] syria forget about
the ukraine
let's let's find out children's
hospitals being blown up in ukraine but
let's find out if she [ __ ] in his bed
look at him i'm on my side of the bed
was human fecal matter
let me hear how he says it
it wasn't a good time human fecal matter
jesus christ
um
so i understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
she was sitting on one side
of the couch i was sitting on the other
she that's when she was trying to
explain
a few things about coachella and
then the
fecal
[Music]
delivery
and say saying that it was the dogs
and i i could i'm sorry i could not
agree with her i've lived with those
dogs i
picked up their fun
it was not
the dogs
[Laughter]
look at his face first of all he's this
is a big win for johnny depp and a big
loss with pirates of caribbeans how
about [ __ ] you guys you got rid of the
best [ __ ] pirate you've ever had for
a crazy lady
you [ __ ] up fecal
delivery vehicle delivery daddy i just
made fecal delivery
can you change me
what's fecal delivery that's a nice way
of saying in court
she [ __ ] the bed because you can't say
that i made a fatal delivery what
happens if he said she [ __ ] in my bed in
court
did they kick you out did they get mad
at you she made a dump
i bet you could say dump she dumped
excuse me objection
[Laughter]
the defendant is using slang she [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my bed yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my bed did you see him smirking
that's what made me laugh so hard
through all of this but this is like
what what can happen to a guy like that
if you get caught up in that romantic
idea that this is my woman and he didn't
even sign a prenup
he was worth like 300 million oh my god
he didn't sign a prenup
what an idiot you know what then he like
uh amber's uh insisted we were in love
we wouldn't need him
and like i didn't expect her to take
[ __ ] [ __ ]
in my bed how long were they even
married for
11 days
i just said they're in virginia and
fairfax virginia that's where the court
is yeah
i wonder if it's like favorable for
plaintiffs there you know because it's a
civil though it's a civil case where
he's suing her for 50 million dollars
it's like a defamation case
the thing is it's like there was a video
or an audio recording that came out
where she was admitting to hitting him
she was admit like she changed this
narrative
and the way she was talking about it
publicly is that he was abusive and that
she you know she was just this victim
she tried to protect him by not telling
anybody and then there's i think that's
roughly it and then there was this audio
recording that he had secretly recorded
where she's talking about hitting him
and he said you punched me and he said
uh i didn't pinch you i hit you i didn't
punch you i hit you that's a good voice
no you punch me
no i did it i didn't punch it
yeah you did
no i did it
you totally
punched me you totally punched me no i
didn't i just i like brushed against you
and you deposited feces in my bed i
think the finger argument when she cut
his finger off
this is the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've
ever yeah where was they what were they
arguing about i want to say it might
have something to do with the prenup
the the finger argument i think it was
about the depositing of feces can you
imagine if it was the other way around
if the woman had 300 million dollars and
the guy was like cutting her finger off
because she wouldn't sign a prenup
he'd be put in jail for the rest
she threw a [ __ ] bottle at him
why did she find out please because i
don't want to get sued he painted with
the blood on his finger after it was cut
during a fight with her during the
testimony of violent argument australia
2005 heard through claimed resulted tip
his finger being cut off was it but what
was the um
what was the reason for it
heard threw two vodka bottles on at him
and when one exploded sliced his finger
to the point where the bone was exposed
oh what was the argument about
i think the argument was a boy then he
then just says what he wrote on the
mirror what had to do with billy bob
reminders
billy bob and easy amber oh no billy bob
thornton [ __ ] her
that guy's just done he [ __ ] he
[ __ ]
jolie he [ __ ] her which is so i mean i
would kill the [ __ ] angelina
how much would you kill there's like a
puppy um like a whole kindergarten
[ __ ] class
[Laughter]
of my own children well back then too
she was super young she was smoking hot
and they were doing the blood thing
where they took each other's blood and
put it in a vial and hung it around
their neck yup
yup they must have been doing wild [ __ ]
together
yeah sometimes them couples them fiery
couples stabbed them together
they get together that's what happens oh
yeah yeah they mix they mix liquids and
yeah [ __ ] throw bottles at each other
yeah and [ __ ] bash each other's heads
into the wall [ __ ] in each other's beds
[ __ ]
we're partying we're rock stars [ __ ]
[Music]
billy bob billy bob thornton insists he
didn't sleep with amber heard he says
it's not true oh that's what he says
well if he's saying that it's probably
not true her eyes
her eyes look it's crazy look in her
eyes yes or
he wants to [ __ ] [ __ ] again oh yeah
and he he's like i didn't but i will now
maybe he wants a [ __ ] again maybe he's
single
and like she contacted him like this is
a [ __ ] like [ __ ] joke he's doing
this to me and it's like it's so
dramatic yeah listen that sucks listen
uh don't worry i mean i'll just
cover for you if you want to deposit
feces in my bag
well okay figal delivery
the [ __ ] it's like
we're getting a chance to see through
this will smith thing
with jada pinkett through this johnny
depp thing with amber heard like
these you can't
they're not just like protected by
publicists anymore it's not like they
can just hide and you think of them as
these impossible people who are without
flaws and then when they die you like
see the autobiography and you're like oh
dude
john crawford was [ __ ] crazy right
that's so true